okay let's move on to your newest crush
do we have to talk about it yes Bobby
says Tony Thornburg is not his number
one hey Tony Tony if you're listening
you're [ __ ] out bro he's number two
now cuz I know you've been in LA couple
of times really since I've announced
that I have a crush on you
no coffee nothing wow so you're out
alright my new guy is you've heard of
South Korea the country
yeah the country dawg okay yeah it was a
Bobby okay I got so to dog like so Korea
bro I got salt oh man so you know anyway
do know do oh so they have a new
president right he's got a bodyguard oh
that guy the bodyguard yeah dude it's
like he's got a man [ __ ] what does that
mean he's got a dick but to me my eyes
probably will you psychologically turn
it into a vagina mostly the balls turn
to labia yeah penis next thing I know I
see vagina but then I'm like eating it
and then all of a sudden it's a dick in
my mouth
well if he's so hit me hit me hit me did
here I said yeah you want him in okay
Youngjae Choi
that's his yet ugh what really yeah and
big people take photos of him like half
of his face around the corner of a room
like people are like they don't give a
[ __ ] about the president they're taking
photos of this a bodyguard and he is
cute as [ __ ] he is kind of Steven unis
yeah thicker and more muscley probably
very good with weapons real-life
assassin you know he's got to be really
good with with you know martial arts or
some type of like yeah distracting it's
like if I there's a photo I saw where
was him and another bodyguard with the
president you know who I feel bad for
the other bodyguard
like he just said there was a table food
like me yeah because he looks like you
know a flat face [ __ ] like me you know
but this other one it's like I don't
think that I know if I was the president
I want my guys up Lee oh for sure ugly
huge I don't want anyone taking a photo
of my bodyguard oh not me how was that
would that be right like you see cameras
I pointed to your left right and you're
like oh my god it's not on me it's on
what is there yang don't you join hey
wait : Joyce's last name because in
Korea and you say that's worth it so
it's choi jung jae choi jung jae yeah
yeah
mixing choy yeah like mrs. minister yeah
i mean if you're that good-looking how
do you even like joe song we is my
favorite well take it back I take it
back but do it in your urban voice oh yo
dawg I take it back
[Music]